Joseph Feingold was an architect and
Holocaust survivor who gained late
notoriety in the 2016 documentary Joe's
violin born in Warsaw Feingold was sent
to Siberia at 17 and spent six years in
labor camps his mother and brother were
killed by the Nazis Feingold came to the
u.s. in 1948 with the violin he got in a
trade for a carton of cigarettes after
the war hello the documentary about his
decision to donate the instrument to a
school and the twelve-year-old girl who
played it was nominated for an Oscar the
attention mystified Feingold what did I
do
you never gave up that's what you did
Joseph Feingold was 97 dr. Julie Butler
was a veterinarian
who ran Harlem's 140 Fifth Street Animal
Hospital for three decades Julie was a
remarkable woman said her husband Claude
very strong fierce very determined the
only african-american graduate in her
class at Cornell's College of Veterinary
Medicine she became president of the
veterinary medicine Association of New
York City and after 9/11 led efforts to
stabilize veterinary care said her
colleague dr. George Goren Julie had so
much more to give especially in times
like now dr. Julie Butler was 62
jong-kook poon lived the immigrant story
of the American dream he worked as an
interpreter for the American military in
South Korea in 1976 aged 39 he
immigrated to the states with his wife
and four kids he sacrificed so much to
give us a better life said his daughter
sue genes second he was just so
tenacious arriving with $500 poon built
a thriving dry-cleaning business in Los
Angeles and mentored others South Korean
immigrants he and his wife young were
married for 53 years Jong Kook poon was
82 dr. Ronald varier was a trauma
surgeon for nearly two decades at st.
Barnabas Hospital in the Bronx New York
the son of a surgeon varier was born and
raised in port-au-prince Haiti he met
his wife dr. Joanne very a fair and
loved Haitian music after the earthquake
hit Haiti in 2010 he went back to help
he was the stalwart of the family our
adviser our pride said his younger
sister Pascal very a a registered nurse
doctor very a survived a heart attack in
2014 that's why this is so devastating
said his wife Joanne dr. Ronald varier
was 59
kriste Guzman was a nurse in Chicago
she liked the excitement she liked
helping people said her cousin jeschill
and Pilar she worked at the Meadowbrook
senior facility where she met her
husband Omar a nursing assistant they
idolized each other said her sister
Kayla Clayton and their kids were her
pride and joy their third child was just
born in December
Omar tested positive too and could not
participate in his wife's funeral the
family stopped the procession in front
of their house to release balloons Crist
Angelyn Castro Guzman was 35 Charles
Robb Roberts was an officer with the
Glen Ridge New Jersey Police Department
said governor Phil Murphy he was the
department's most senior patrol officer
and a beloved literally beloved presence
in the community it was his lifelong
dream to be a police officer said his
wife Alice
he'd make a connection make people feel
like humans ten year old son Gavin led
his mother and two sisters in the
funeral procession wearing his father's
hat Charles Robb Roberts was 45
[Music]